P.M. ON FOX NATION.
AINSLEY?
JILLIAN: THANKS, JILLIAN.
SHOCKING IMAGES FROM OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER SHOW MERELY
1,000 MIGRANTS SURRENDERING TO
BORDER PATROL AS A NEW REPORT
REVEALS BORDER OFFICIALS PICKED
UP MORE UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
THAN EVER BEFORE, EVER BEFORE.
WITH A RECORD 19,000 IN JULY.
THE NUMBERS ONLY FUELING CALLS
FOR VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS TO BE
FIRED AS THE BORDER CZAR
INCLUDING NEXT GUEST.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY HOST OF OUTNUMBERED
KAYLEIGH McENANY JOINS US NOW
GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING, AINSLEY.
AINSLEY: THIS IS CRAZY.
THESE ARE CHILDREN COME TO OUR
BORDER WITHOUT THEIR PARENT.
KAMALA HARRIS, WHERE IS SHE IN
ALL OF THIS.
>> SHE IS ABSENT.
SHE IS UNSERIOUS ABOUT THIS TASK
OF BEING THE BORDER CZAR.
IT’S WHY IT TOOK HER NEARLY 100
DAYS TO ACTUALLY GO TO THE
BORDER.
AND WHEN SHE GOT THERE, AINSLEY,
SHE STOOD UP AND SAID WE HAVE
MADE GREAT PROGRESS.
HOW CAN YOU SAY THAT WHEN THERE
IS A 21 YEAR HIGH IN ENCOUNTERS
AT THE BORDER.
A RECORD HIGH AS YOU NOTE FOR
THE MONTH OF JULY WITH
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS, THIS IS A
DISASTER.
AND THEN SHE LAUGHS ABOUT IT SHE
SAYS WELL, I HAVEN’T BEEN TO
EUROPE WHEN ASKED ABOUT GOING TO
THE BORDER.
SHE IS FAILING AT THIS TASK.
THAT’S WHY SHE HAS THE LOWEST
APPROVAL RATING OF ANY VICE
PRESIDENT IN THE LAST HALF
CENTURY.
AINSLEY: I WANT TO ALSO TALK TO
YOU ABOUT COVID-19.
YESTERDAY, THE PRESIDENT WAS
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE FLIP WRONG
OF THE CDC AND ALL OF THESE EVER
CHANGING MANDATES OR GUIDANCE.
DR. MICHAEL OSTERHOLM, HE WAS A
FORMER BIDEN COVID ADVISER.
IS HE SAYING THE CLOTH MASK
IRAQI SECURITY FORCES
INEFFECTIVE.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> KNOW TODAY THAT MANY OF THE
FACE CLOTH COVERINGS A THAT
PEOPLE ARE EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING
THE VIRUS.
WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT BETTER
MASKING.
WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT N-95
RESPIRATORS.
AINSLEY: HERE WE GO AGAIN.
WHAT’S YOUR REACTION?
>> HERE WE GO AGAIN.
THE MASK WE HAVE BEEN TOLD TO
WEAR SOMEHOW INEFFECTIVE AND
N-95 RESPIRATORS.
NO THANKS.
WE ARE IN A DIFFERENT STABLE OF
THE PANDEMIC.
WE DON’T NEED MASKS.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING VACCINATED.
AINSLEY, I HAVE GOT TO SAY ABOUT
THE BIDEN MESSAGING HERE, I WAS
IN THE ADMINISTRATION WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP GOT IN FRONT OF
THAT PODIUM EVERY DAY FLANKED BY
A PANOPLY OF EXPERTS, THE CDC,
DR. FAUCI WAS THERE.
DR. BIRX AND LOOKED THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE IN THE EYE AND TOOK
QUESTIONS FOR NEARLY AN HOUR.
HE MADE PPE AVAILABLE TO THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
HE MADE THE VACCINE AVAILABLE.
HE MADE THERAPEUTICS AVAILABLE.
JOE BIDEN WAS HANDED A PRETTY
GOOD HAND OF CARDS.
AND HE HAS SQUANDERED IT.
AND HIS MESSAGING IS JUST ALL
OVER THE MAP AND A TOTAL
DISASTER.
AINSLEY: I MEAN, MY GOSH, WHAT
ARE THEY GOING TO TELL US NEXT?
HOW IS THIS GOING TO AFFECT YOU
AND YOUR FAMILY?
>> YEAH, EXACTLY.
MANDATES ARE CLEARLY WHAT’S
NEXT.
YOU KNOW, YOU HAD THE CDC
DIRECTOR GO ON WITH BRET BAIER
AND SUGGEST THAT MAYBE WE WOULD
HAVE A VACCINE MANDATE.
THEN SHE WENT AND CLEANED THAT
UP.
LOOK, THEY ARE SLOWLY TIPTOEING
IN THAT DIRECTION WITH JOE BIDEN
YESTERDAY TACITLY APPROVING THE
NEW YORK MANDATE THAT YOU HAVE
TO BE VACCINATED TO EAT IN A
RESTAURANT.
IT’S RIDICULOUS AND ORWELLIAN